hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Season five a fortnight Battle Royale
has now ended which means it's time to
look back at everything it gave us and
break down those Easter eggs those
cultural references a few memes and all
the changes that came to the map for
nostalgia purposes and of course we'll
look back at the event which in season 5
was all about a rolling Hugh Bob death
season 5 began on July 12th and ran
until September 27th 2018 the story
continued from the rocket event in
season four as the rift in the sky
dragged vehicles and locations from
other worlds hence the title world
collide before we reviewed the season
let's first look at the easter eggs and
the nod to pop culture found over the
last few months
starting with emotes and characters the
two look sad or inspired wrestlers were
added along with this amount in season 5
do you recognise the end pose
yeah that's hulk hogan's calling sign
brother
I wonder if Usain Bolt stole the idea
the female that you dark-skinned in
particular known as dynamo also wears a
mask very reminiscent of the wrestler
sexy star that's legitimately her ring
name I promise her mask is designed with
a star across the forehead and it
matches up almost perfectly with dynamo
during the time this skin was revealed
sexy star was in the news after
deliberately injuring a fellow wrestler
in a match who said wrestling isn't real
the season starts at pack the ACE
brought back an easter egg I missed a
few seasons ago the back bling satchel
full of cash uses monopoly style money
complete with llama decals back in
season 3 the first emote to use the
Monopoly cash was the make it rain emote
when the GarageBand GarageBand however
when the GarageBand set released it used
typical 80s rock tropes to build the
characters I mean the stage Slayer is
slash and Duff from Guns and Roses
thrown together in a homage to the days
when music wasn't just care alarms and
beeps thanks Skrillex but it's the
glider which appeared alongside the
rockers which grabbed my attention - the
wings this beaut is a callback to the
1980s again
and the Back to the Future film starring
Michael J Fox and the famous DeLorean
the loading screen even has the iconic
rubber burns on the road before takeoff
and it's even in the small print two
extra points for the squishy tomato head
on the antenna speaking of gliders
another overpriced glider I couldn't
resist
is this shark with a laser on its head
the laser jump is here in homage to
Austin Powers and the supervillain dr.
evil and his desire to have sharks with
laser beams attached to their head and
that is to have sharks with frickin
laser beams attached to their heads
jumping over to the battle past there
was this beauty amount you're awesome to
unlock which takes inspiration from
James Brown and his silky dance moves
the two plus two equals four remote is
here thanks to fire in the booth it's a
BBC Radio 1 show which gives lyricists a
platform to show their skills every so
often they have comedy acts on such as
big shack and roll safe if brawl safe
looks familiar he based his look on
Eddie Murphy in the 1980s and this
moment he starts talking about his gran
ring who can speak French mixed with big
shacks are some mathematics to is formed
madness one that's free quick mess and
we now have this fortnight emote Ubisoft
Ubisoft ooby's how do you say it Ubisoft
our Ubisoft
Ubisoft Rainbow six series can be seen
with this stuff alot of affection in the
battle pass with sledgehammer who bears
a resemblance to Blackbeard
luckily fortnight sledgehammer hasn't
been nerfed into oblivion yes during
season 5 the start and end characters in
the battle pass were based around Norse
myth the Huntress and Ragnarok they were
joined at the end of the season by
Valkyrie and the frost wing the frost
wing in particular the biggest glider to
date looks familiar to me but I couldn't
place it
asking around people suggested that the
mount resembles World of Warcraft wyvern
mount and even the lynch king inspired
sindragosa
the animation itself is taken from Game
of Thrones and the vissarion Dragon
which was resurrected and became an ice
dragon I know there'll be at least one
smartass in the comments who says
technically these are wyverns not
dragons let's agree to make a note here
that dragons have four legs and separate
wings and wyverns have two
with their wings attached to their arms
every day's of school day swipe is a nod
to Millie Rock probably the most
renowned video for this is by Ron Purdy
who has been watched Millie rocking in
New York almost 20 million times when
I'm saying this the breakdown emote is a
homage to a dance troupe known as the
kynges the emote takes five parts of
their dance routines from many different
pieces of their choreography the dance
therapy emote on the other hand is a
Kevin Bacon reference to the greatest
film of all time
Footloose in this one hour keV just
wants to dance in a town where it's band
time to let out that anger in a dance
this is what I do every time YouTube D
monetize my video so about ten times a
week the twist emote is our seasonal nod
to John Travolta and pop fiction this
time is his silky moves at a dance
competition with boomer Thurman it was a
teenage wedding oh oh well the shaky top
emote is another reference to Jim Carrey
this season it's from the mask and is
impressive maracas worth at the end of
season five the vivacious emotes brung
up this is a reference to that bloody
annoying desk bus detail song which
ruined our ear holes for months a little
more accurately though it's a nod to the
despedido girl who must dance every time
she hears the song regardless of where
she is pretty embarrassing for her but
dang she's got moose the pumpernickel
dance is taken from The Andy Samberg
movie hot rod from 2007 oh my god I'm
old as 11 years ago cool beans
when the aerobic characters hit the star
so did this emote work it out is in
homage to the 1988 national aerobic
fitness championship show which was also
parodied by key and Peele in 2014 the
fabled techno viking found his place in
fortnight which links up well with the
NOS theme the intensity emotes shows
what a serious music lover does when
their favorite tune comes on
[Music]
when praise the tomato appeared in the
shop it took the returning tomato temple
theme and blended it with dark souls the
praise the Sun emote in fact another
emote added in season five was fancy
feet which takes line dancing undertones
and merges it with the King of Pop
Michael Jackson and these moves
if you grab the Nordic horn at the end
of season five keep an ear out when you
use it there's a small possibility that
the horn malfunctions and the epic sound
becomes a wet fart lovely remember the
boogie down contest from season three if
you win this competition your emo will
forever be immortalized into the game
well the winning emot-- finally found
its way into the game and it was free to
anyone who sets up to factor safety
checks on their account literally a
reward for securing your account great
work there epic games press still a
terrible dance though
hey the power chord character returned
in season by a great chance to throw in
an Easter egg I missed a few seasons
back the guitar she holds and the rock
emote synonymous with her uses a guitar
made famous by Dimebag Darrell he was a
metal god and performed with
heavyweights Pantera anthrax and many
others sadly though he was shot and
killed whilst performing back in 2004 at
least one of the fortnight developers
was inspired by his music as Lars in
save the world plays the same guitar
whilst ascending to the heavens so
season 5 brought in elements from other
dimensions and worlds let's quickly
recap at the end of season 3 a meteor
was seen heading towards the island in
season 4 it hit and the meteor housed
the visitor who created a time-bending
rocket which caused a crack in time and
space above the map items and locations
from other worlds began to fall through
the cracks and as season 5 begins drift
from our world was dragged into
fortnight alongside new updates to the
map the der burger which vanished from
greasy Grove reappeared to the right of
pleasant park further east
Aniki a third was replaced with a golf
club complete with functional golf holes
whilst I'm talking about new mechanics
in season 5 the basketball and the beach
ball became regular pastimes in
fortnight which made for lots of fun
when sneaking up on people rifts became
pivotal during season 5 as entering one
of these bad boys were throws up into
the air and allow us to dive bomb our
foes these were regularly found around
the moai those Easter Island heads which
were added this season to moisty Maya
and the surrounding areas in the lower
southeast were completely replaced with
a section of route 66 complete with
functional speed gun dinosaurs and a
Donald Trump look-alike and numerous
truck stops - the grass became sand to
give us additional biomes to experience
the key town here was Paradise Palms a
summer holiday village which became the
second most landed spot after tilted
towers the dirt track was replaced with
a super mario kart inspired racing track
which again was fully functional and
with the introduction of the all-terrain
karts we could forget about killing each
other and instead raced to be the best
speaking of Mario Kart the ATK's used
the same slide to boost mechanic as back
in the SNES days the ATK's themselves
have golf bags but the golf clubs have
been replaced with pickaxes oh and those
hanging dice are
friends the burger and the tomato head
Oh segue tomato town which lost its head
last season suddenly reappeared but the
large metallic red head was replaced
with a stone carved statue on August
23rd to be precise an update to the maps
of tomato town replaced with tomato
temple linking the disappearance of the
tomato dude to time travel back to
ancient times but as of yet there are no
concrete evidence here so let's move on
oh by the way August 23rd was also the
time the rift began to close in the sky
other small differences to the map
included the missing nom sign from
retail Row reappearing above risky reals
which was also finally repaired after
the meteor event this venue went on to
show fan made mini movies to enjoy
during matches
speaking of reconstruction finally over
weeks and months the building destroyed
over until tea towers was finally
finished and enjoyed its opening day
good things come to those who wait over
dusty divot where the meteor landed the
spot became overgrown and recaptured by
Nature later in the season a museum and
cafe opened at the former dusty divot
named dusty diner inside the museum are
the original fragments of the meteor
which I think will play a part in future
seasons but also take a look around and
you'll see a few Easter eggs like the
image of the original dusty Depot to
remind us of simpler times there's even
a viewing area overlooking the divot to
educate newcomers and finally the last
and greatest update to the map in my
eyes anyway is Viking Valhalla replacing
the house one mountain below the
villains lair again this linked into
nast theme and even had snow what's
great about this is that the clues left
in season 4 such as the anchor became
new places the anchor was from an aww
[ __ ] the stage wagon which I was
convinced would be a western themed
location became an exhibit outside
Paradise Palms and the dinosaur bones
well they're still there
we did get dinosaurs but suddenly they
weren't real that's enough about the map
updates let's look at the biggest Easter
Egg to come out of season 5 and it's due
to a youtuber named muse elk and his
exploits attempting to rescue a stranded
opponent picture the scene Chapa doodle
renamed
accidentally found an area of the map
which was below the build limit in the
game thus making him stuck and unable to
compete music saw this as an opportunity
to help out a brother
from another mother unused in a TK to
drop down and use as a jump pad sadly
well see for yourself father happened
I'm coming for you boy I'm coming for
you hold on he's here Oh No surprisingly
he murdered chaffeur doodles but his
method of escape did actually work epic
games updated the area leaving a set of
tires to help anyone who finds himself
in the same predicament but moreover
they installed a gravestone to honor
chapo doodle and musics heroics pretty
damn cool touch more of this kind of
stuff please epic during the birthday
event cake could be consumed and
everywhere was covered in balloons but
down in greasy grow the balloon whose
were placed over storm drains in homage
to it
down at the rave in yonder yard you'll
notice there are more images to save the
world and the horses that we fight in
that game mode if anyone plays save the
world like me please put STW in the chat
i shall find you ok back to the story
let's go back to those load screens once
the rifts in time and space opened the
drift character was dragged onto the
island alongside the fabled derp burger
bright bomber and her crew showed drift
around the island and especially the new
areas to discover midway through season
5 the crack in the sky began to burn
down a group of cactuses cacti cactus
cacti whichever is correct once all the
cacti were demolished the rift did this
a mysterious cube was created which
gifted shield went close enough but
would repel any damage at the closest
player to the cube so what did we all do
we all killed each other
for a while which was fun eventually the
cube began to roll around the map and
left Nordic runes in the ground linking
back to the norstein we found in the
battle paths and the theory of Ragnarok
bringing the end to the current world
over the next month the cube went about
its business including smashing down the
building and tilted towers which has
been under construction since season
four began epic just love to trollers
back to the loading screens saw the
arrival of the enforcers which look like
intergalactic police we'll have to wait
to see what happens here because even on
the last day of season 5 nothing has
been confirmed watch this space so the
cube finally made it over to loot lake
and this
[Music]
the cube melted into loot lake causing
the top layer to become a repellant kind
of trampoline gel loot lake became [ __ ]
lake doesn't have the same ring to it
now on the last day of season five we
are all speculating what will happen
next will the cube rise out of the lake
will wailing woods finally open up that
bloody bunker will the motel become a
saloon so I can live out my cowboy
fantasies time will tell I suppose
finally the umbrella for winning a
season five was the summer holiday
inspired Sun umbrella we did it you know
we finished it we go through it season
five don't understand what did I miss
I can't have got everything because that
was a lot of work for quite a few weeks
let me know in the comments below in
fact if you've seen any Easter eggs in
season six put them below and I will
make sure to put them in the next video
and if I don't find them myself I will
make sure you get a name check anyway I
imagine from Playstation grenades and
I'm going for a lay down it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]